about ways to reduce EMF and improve baby's sleep quality.
Well, the number one way that you could remove,
you could reduce EMF,
and the proper way to say it is to reduce
because you're never going to remove EMFs.
Unless you put your whole house in a fair-day cage.
That would be the only way to do it,
which I'd be enthusiastic because that's not possible.
But to reduce EMFs,
turn off your Wi-Fi.
Have your baby's room away from the Wi-Fi.
This can be extremely difficult
if you're living in an apartment building or a towed house.
So that's why you, at all possible,
you don't live in an apartment building or a towed house.
So when you talk about EMFs,
you're getting the most amount of EMFs
from 5G towers that are near your house
and your Wi-Fi and your cell phones.
That's your getting your greatest number of EMFs,
the greatest quality of EMFs.
And if you're living in an apartment building or a towed house,
how many people within 150 foot radius
have a Wi-Fi going?
A lot.
So you just think of that exposure of EMFs.
Your neighbor right next to the wall, right next to you,
has a Wi-Fi, the neighbor on the other side wall.
That's adjacent to you as a Wi-Fi.
The people upstairs.
And adjacent to them, the people downstairs
and adjacent to them with apartment or towed house.
You're getting a high exposure to EMFs.
So just turn it off.
Your Wi-Fi is good,
but your neighbors aren't doing that.
So it's very difficult.
And so if you had your own home that's far enough away
from your neighbor's Wi-Fi,
better off you're going to be.
If you're concerned about your child,
look at even their adjacent rooms,
where they could be getting Wi-Fi exposure.
Even if you have a house and you're living in your old house,
but the next house is only 20 feet away.
And if those neighbors have their Wi-Fi on that outside wall,
that could be a fact that can be crossing.
You could see it when you look up your computer
to search for a connection,
you could see all the Wi-Fi that are in the area.
So that's going to be your greatest source of EMFs.
Keeping your phones away from your bed
and your children's bed, of course,
keeping them away from screen time as much as possible.
You're talking about your child not being able to sleep well.
If your child is getting screen time,
hopefully a little baby isn't getting screen time,
but it's not uncommon that people these days will allow
their two-year-old to sit and watch movies or something.
If they're sitting and watching movies,
remember those screens I'm sitting here looking at a computer right now.
This screen on the computer is resonated at 60 hertz.
All screens resonated at 60 hertz,
whether it's your television, your phone,
or your computer screens or whatever.
It's basically entraining your brain at 60 hertz.
Your brain needs to get down to about seven hertz
for you to be able to fall asleep.
So if you're training your brain at 60 hertz
and you can't figure out why you can't fall asleep
after looking at your phone,
because you just did brain entraining forever
or ever alone sitting here for an hour,
or doing this talk right now,
you need to get out and grow yourself
or get away from the screen for a period of time
to get your brain to calm back down to a normal brain level.
So it's a very high-hertz that you're training your brain at.
So it's not just EMFs that can keep you away,
but certainly EMFs are a major cause of issues in our environment
and that you cannot ignore anymore.
It's a real thing.
So good question.
Do everything you possibly can to reduce EMFs.
Just think of where the sources of those are.
There are different grounding things that you could use.
There's EMFs that are coming from your just your electrical system
in your house. You got wires running all around your house
up to the light up there and down to the wall over here.
There's a phenomena called dirty electricity
that gives off EMFs of your house.
We have some products in our store called SATIC products.
That's the brand that helps get rid of that dirty electricity.
We have that in our house.
I have it here at the office because that's a real thing as well.
So you just try to do as many things as you possibly can.
In our store we have a lot of EMFs.
We talked about a Faraday cage if you could put your house in a Faraday cage.
But you can put your phone in a Faraday cage.
You could put your router in a Faraday cage.
We have those.
We have cloth Faraday cages that you could actually slip your phone into
and you can't just leave it in there because you won't get any calls
because it's a true Faraday cage and you won't get any messages.
But when you take it out then all these messages will come through.
But it does block what you're getting from your phone.
I did a video a couple weeks ago on EMFs from a computer.
And quite honestly, you really don't get that many EMFs from a computer.
I actually had it on my other computer and I was testing EMFs.
But when you're connected to the Wi-Fi and you're getting information
downloading on your computer, that's when you're going to get an EMFs.
It was kind of odd because I was talking about EMFs for the right computer.
And then my meter kept bouncing up and down.
But I was filming this video with my phone.
And when my phone got closer to the meter, that's what it just bounced way up.
So the majority of EMFs were coming from my phone.
Hardly any EMFs from the computer itself.
So it's those are the kind of things you just want to be aware of.
You can buy a very inexpensive EMF meter at your local hardware store.
You could test your stuff too and see, you know, how to best protect yourself.
I often share a story years ago I had a patient whose child started getting seizures.
And when we tested the child with kinesiology, it came up due to EMFs.
So I had to question, we're just kind of putting out our Sherlock Holmes hat, try to figure out.
This is what computers just were barely knew on the market and been out on the market maybe 10 years.
I can't remember, this is back in the early 2000s or maybe late 90s.
And the dad had just purchased a brand new laptop and that is when the child started having seizures.
And we tested the laptop and it was like off the chart with EMFs.
All he did is bring his laptop back, his brand new laptop.
So we could bring it back to Best Buy at the time, traded it for new laptop.
There must have been some little laptop worked fine.
But there must have been some little short in it that was just, I don't have no idea to this day.
But then the kids seizures went away.
So we're doctors to say EMFs are causing issues.
It's just absolute foolishness.
There's enough data out there now, even though most of it's been suppressed by the cell phone companies because they don't want you to tell them.
But I don't think anybody's going to get rid of their cell phones, even if more and more data came out that cell phones are causing brain cancer.
Happy with cell users cell phones.
It's just, you know, it's just the lifestyle that we have grown accustomed to use.
Anything you could do to get rid of EMFs at help of Fs with grow-deed sheets, things like that would be better off to do.